[Applaudissements]
c'est très gentil et bon semaine très
chargée en accu Benjamin puisqu'air
c'était votre anniversaire je déconne
bien évidemment parler des
manifestations on va y revenir juste
après mais juste avant comme tous les
mercredis je vous ai préparé les
meilleurs moments des interview
politique de ces derniers jours dans le
gueux à droite c'était con
allez rêver compliqué pour Marc Fauvel
le journaliste de France Info j'espère
juste que Geoffroy route Baisieux n'est
pas trop susceptible on a besoin
évidemment des investissements étrangers
en France mais de Baisieux président du
Médoc Oliver
qu'on puisse dire c'est qui savent
mettre à l'aise sur Europe 1 peut-être
même un peu trop on a une demi-heure
d'entretien Olivier du stop mettez-vous
à enlever votre cravate peut-être
[Musique]
dti hyper confiant mais à force de
baisser sa garde bah ils ont vite fait
regretter d'avoir ouvert son cœur
comment ça va ça va très bien ça va très
bien ça va très bien c'est beaucoup de
travail mais ça va très bien attendez un
ballon à votre effigie où vous êtes
égauxiez à l'Assemblée nationale de la
première ministre aurait dit qu'elle
avait 50% de débile dans son
gouvernement comment ça va
ambiance festive sur LCI alors que ça se
passe ça se passe pas sur le plateau ça
se passe dans la tête de Gérard Larcher
qui a changé d'humeur en 2 secondes
peut-être une faute d'auteur puisque
j'étais le ministre de ça c'est
l'introduit non mais il a introduit dans
le code des autres tout seul
et enfin on dit que le sénateur
Jean-Pierre Sueur a une info de la plus
haute importance à nous annoncer
[Musique]
je voulais vous dire que moi je suis
allé avant 13h manger rapidement une
part de quiche
ok
on aurait peut-être pu se passer cette
info Jean-Pierre oui bon comme je le
disais nouvelle semaine de manifestation
à travers la France et pour cette
dixième mobilisation bFM TV a vu les
choses en grand avec une bande-annonce
digne des plus gros Marvel peut-être un
peu tout match sachant qu'on parle des
retraites
dans la rue nouvelle journée de
mobilisation
demain contre la réforme des retraites
avec toujours la menace de violence et
de débordement retraite jusqu'où ira la
colère BFM qui était chaud patate au
point d'envoyer leur journaliste à 7h du
mat pour couvrir le manif qui commence à
14h forcément bah il y avait pas grand
chose à dire le matin alors écoutez pour
le moment il n'y a rien à signaler on a
vu quelques camions de police tournée
mais mais rien de pour le moment assis
assigné
avec un blocage à l'aéroport Charles de
Gaulle et heureusement qu'elle s'y a
dégainé sa journaliste la moins
catastrophiste image forte de ce matin
c'est vraiment regarder ces gens qui
sortent de leur voiture pour ne pas
manquer leur avion on voit des familles
des enfants de finir leur trajet à pied
certains cours dans la boue désespérés
en colère c'est vraiment
l'Apocalypse
mon dieu des voyageurs qui devaient être
à bout de nerf vu que c'était
l'apocalypse de ce filtrage bloquant
donc on est parti beaucoup plus tôt de
la maison on le savait on s'y attendait
c'était prévu
donc non non la ça me dérange pas je
suis content justement de voir que ça
bouge je suis assez fier de ça la vérité
donc c'est génial alors si vous allez au
travail en transport à éviter de croiser
cette journaliste qui risque
de vous à regarder BFM alors que vous en
avez pas grand chose à faire comme cette
dame
regarde en même temps et bien oui
évidemment BFM TV elle est très fan
c'est vrai
la meilleure chaîne d'info de vrais
champions Zoé la bonne idée d'envoyer un
journaliste cardiaque en manif
[Musique]
et puis j'ai une pensée pour Fred à
gréviste qui a eu le droit à la pire
musique chantée par les manifestants
pendant son duplex ou alors peut-être
qu'il voulait lui faire passer un
message je sais pas vous financièrement
comment vous faites Fred avec 10
manifestations alors nouvelle ce qu'on a
fait c'est que quand il y a eu les
manies par exemple en 2019
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon après la politique et l'actu j'ai
aussi checker les réseaux sociaux pour
vous montrer les meilleures vidéos de
cette semaine qui sont passées en France
que Benjamin adore elle reste de la
chronique il s'en fout mais la météo des
réseaux franchement c'est vrai tout le
reste je m'en voulais ça j'aime bien la
météo des réseaux on commence à ardent
tout ce papa il pensera deux fois avant
d'entrer dans la chambre de son enfance
OK
une petite réunion de famille à Toulon
où les premiers invités de ce gars
viennent d'arriver à la Maison
d'Ailleurs
premier jour de travail compliqué pour
cet employé à Toulouse mon avis pourra
plus jamais de sac de sa vie
et oui direction le fast-food à Besançon
où ce client se fait en tu kiffes en
sont trop savoir pourquoi
vous voulez
si vous croisez un pote dans la rue
évitez trop détourner son attention
comme Arles salut Leandro fais un coucou
à Cindy
dans des circonstances un peu spéciales
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup